[Music]
one of the central characters in ursula
k le guin's sixth earth sea novel the
other wind
is alder a village sorcerer whose craft
whose skill whose power
is of
mending and this is going to be
particularly
important in a thematic way
for him and for others and indeed for
the entire
narrative universe of earth sea
he has to make a
sacrifice of his very power the thing
that gives him his identity the meaning
of his
existence in many respects and he goes
through something kind of similar to
what ged the ark mage does in tehanu
having to find
his own way
once his power is gone he doesn't have
quite so much time to do it because he's
drawn into
an incredibly important task in which he
gets to as he frames it mend
the world
and
in the beginning of the work we find out
that he's having these these dreams
where he goes to the
land of the dead the dry land and to the
wall of stones the first time he sees
his wife then he sees his old master and
then it's all the dead coming and
wanting to touch him and
you know he brings this up to the
masters at rock and to get and and
people are trying to piece together
what's actually
happening with this gad sends him to
havnor and this is one of the great
crises it's clear that something is
wrong
in
the dry land and the relations between
the dead and the living
there is a suggestion
that it could be that
alder is able to go to the
dry land and the stone wall
precisely because of his great
love for his wife the love that they
feel together a love that is of two
menders
which can't be broken because it's not
in their nature to do
breaking things and this is when he's
talking with ged in chapter one
he alder is talking about the various
conjectures
about how this came about and alder says
he said it was maybe my wife and i
didn't know how to be parted only how to
be joined that it was not my doing but
maybe ours together because we drew to
each the other like drops of quicksilver
and there's you know also perhaps the
idea that you know he he can't actually
break this thing that he's formed now
and so
alder is not a cause but you could say a
catalyst along with his wife and there's
some interesting discussions there about
the nature of love
much later in the work
the
the wizard from roque
onyx suggests to alder that if he wants
to have
relief from these dreams maybe he should
go talk to
the pelnish wizard
uh
seppl because sepal
is from this tradition that
knows more about these things so i'm
just going to read this a little bit
palm the greatest island west of havnor
had the reputation of being an uncanny
place
their lords had in ancient times refused
fealty to the kings of enlarge and
hovnor their wizards did not go to rock
for their training the pelnish lore
which called upon the old powers of the
earth was widely believed to be
dangerous if not
sinister right and then a little bit
later onyx says they know more than we
do about these matters most of our art
of summoning comes from the pelnish lore
thorian was a
master of it misused it has brought only
harm but it may be only our ignorance
that led us to use it wrongly it goes
back to very ancient times there may be
knowledge in it we've lost seppel is a
wise man and a mage i think he should be
with us
and he might help you if you can trust
him so they go and they
visit sepal
they talk for for quite a while
and finally sepal
says
would you accept the touch of the
wizardry of palm and alder says
we say on my island the man drowning
doesn't ask what the rope cost if you
can keep me from that place even for a
night you'll have my heart's thanks
little is that his worth in return for
such a
gift and so then seppel is engaging a
little bit of diagnostics there
and he says okay so
this is going to cost you what is the
price that you're going to have to pay
your power
your
your capacity for mending your magic
your your skill
and alder says
all right
i'm only a mender it's not a great power
to give up sepal says
it's your living and alder says it was
my life once
but that's gone and then supple says
well you know maybe your gift will come
back to you when what must happen has
happened i can't promise that i will try
to restore what i can of what i take
from you but we're all walking in the
night now on ground we don't know
so if i spare your dream at that price
will you thank me and alder says i will
what's the little good of my gift
against the great evil my ignorance
could do if you spare me the fear i live
in now the fear that i may do evil i'll
thank you to the end of my life so alder
is not just giving up his power
to purchase an end to dreams that are
bothering him
he's beset by a fear he thinks that he
may be the conduit for something
terrible that's about to happen to
earthsea and he wants to forestall that
so he is willing to give up his power
and they engage in a ritual that invokes
the powers of the earth at aurun a holy
site that has been unfortunately defiled
by the hovnorians
who are not particularly keen on on that
sort of thing but the pelnish wizard
knows what to do and they take away
his power
after that there's a very interesting
description
on the one hand like it says he found
himself treated and considered to be one
of the wizards he could do nothing about
it though it embarrassed him lest onyx
and supple should think he was claiming
equality with them
and it also troubled him because he was
now not even a sorcerer so on the one
hand he's he's got an elevated status
and he's sort of like you know getting
to talk shop and hang out with the
master practitioners from roke and from
from palm
on the other hand he doesn't have his
power and it's not just a loss of
that power
something else is going on
his gift was gone he had no power at all
he knew it as surely as he would have
known the loss of his sight the
paralysis of his hand
he could not have mended a broken
picture now unless with glue and he
would have done it badly because he had
never had to do it
so there's that aspect but then there's
something more
beyond the craft he had lost was
something else something larger
than the craft that was gone
its loss left him as his wife's death
had in a blankness in which no joy new
new thing was
or would ever be nothing could happen
nothing could change this is a
great description of what it feels like
to have lost more than you thought you
were going to
lose and it recalls the loss of his wife
the one who
loved him who he loved and who you know
had so much in common with him they
learned from each other they practiced
their art of mending together and we're
about to
have a family when she dies in
childbirth
but going on it says not having known of
this larger aspect of his gift until he
lost it he pondered on it wondering
about its nature
it was like knowing the way to go he
thought like knowing the direction of a
home
not a thing one could identify or even
say much about but a connection on which
everything else
depended that is what he gave up in
addition to the more manifest aspects of
his craft without it he was desolate he
was
useless and again i think you can see a
parallel here to ged who has lost his
power has given it up also sacrificed it
for the good of earth see
in
tahanu the fourth novel
it finishes with this but at least he
did no harm
so in a way this was very successful
now at the very end of the work they go
to the wall
of stones and alder says
we're going to
we have to mend the world we have to
break the wall
and
he's saying this to hanu
and he says maybe the others can
help us
and so um
they they go and uh
the others
you know figure in with them the
patterner the summoner the door keeper
sepal gamble onyx lebanon all of them
gather around the wall
and they help to undo it tenar and
cesarok are left there while everybody
else is out of their body just as
spirits at the wall and cesarok asks
well what should we
do tnr and she antennae says where to
keep the house
and
what do they do they actually do
manage to pull the wall apart bit by bit
and create a breach in it which now
opens up the dry land
to the rest of earth sea and indeed to
the rest of
the land that it was carved out from on
the other wind
so there's this great description here
i'm actually going to read two little
passages tahanu came up beside him help
me he said he she put her hands on the
stone the human hand and the burnt clog
lip gripping it as well as she could and
gave a lifting tug the stone moved a
little and a little more push it she
said together they pushed it slowly out
of place grating a heart on the rock
beneath it till it fell on the far side
of the wall with a heavy thump the next
stone was smaller together they could
lift it up out of its place they let it
drop in the dust on the near side a
little bit later alder could scarcely
move the great stone his hands around
but the summoner was beside him stooping
with his shoulder against it and said
now together they pushed it till it over
balanced and dropped with that same
final heavy thump on the far side of the
wall
then there's a vast soft cry among the
shadows on the other side like the sound
of a sea on a hollow shore their
darkness surged up against the wall but
alder looked up
and saw that it was no longer dark
light moved in the sky where the stars
had never moved quick sparks of fire in
the dark west
coalescing that was tejano's voice he
looked at her she was gazing upward
westward she had no eye for earth
and then we see that tahanu
turns back into
the dragon that she's never been but has
always been the entire time fire ran
along her hands her arms into her hair
into her face and body
flamed up into great wings above her
head and lifted her into the air a
creature all fire blazing
beautiful
who else comes
alder is there he held in his hands
forgotten a chinking stone he'd wrench
from the wall to loosen a larger rock he
watched the dead go free
at last he saw her among them he tossed
the stone aside and then stepped forward
lily has come lily he said she saw him
and smiled and held her hand out to him
he took her hand and they crossed
together into the sunlight
this is the end of alder reunited now
with his his wife in death the dead can
finally
pass on
into whatever existence follows next to
be on the other wind or to rejoin the
earth whatever it might happen to be
alder is made whole
through his sacrifices
and
his sacrifice of himself helps to
mend the world although definitely not
on his own this is a
collaborative
redemption that takes place
you